welcome everybody to the Macmillan
Center I'm Ian Shapiro the current
director and we're delighted to be
hosting IRA Katznelson as this year's
Henry L Stimson lecturer funding for the
lecture series comes from an anonymous
donor in honor of Henry L Stimson Yale
College 1889 an attorney and statesman
whose government service culminated with
his tenure as Secretary of War during
World War two
the Stimson lectures are published as
books by Yale University Press before
introducing our speaker let me just say
that at the conclusion of today's
lecture there will be a reception on the
second floor common room to which
everybody is invited professor
Katznelson is the Ruggles professor of
political science and history at
Columbia and noted for his research on
American politics inequality social
knowledge and institutions he's written
many books and his 2013 fear itself' the
New Deal and the origins of our time was
awarded the Bancroft prize in history
and the Woodrow Wilson foundation prize
in America in the American political
science it is a stunning tour-de-force
it's very difficult at this time in the
history of the world to have written a
new book on the New Deal that is
actually better than its predecessors
but IRA managed to do that other books
include when affirmative action was
white again a really remarkable book
which I often teach and he recently
published southern nation Congress and
white supremacy after reconstruction
co-authored with David Bateman and John
Lipinski a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences in the
American Philosophical Society professor
Katz Nelson is former president of both
the American Political Science
Association and the Social Science
Research Council which he took from
insolvency
into great financial health before
passing it on last year to a successor
so those of us who benefit from the
Social Science Research Council are
going to be indebted to Ira of long off
to his now five-year term has expired
he's here to give three lectures on the
overall theme of exegesis exigencies I'm
sorry from impermanent emergencies to
enduring exceptions we always like to
say when we have speakers that the topic
is timely whether it is or not but in
fact it's hard to imagine a more timely
subject than the one that he's chosen
today's the first of three called dolls
nightmare
his next lecture will be tomorrow called
liberalism's edge and Thursday's lecture
will be on negotiating the rule of law
and we're looking forward I hope you'll
join us for all three of these lectures
so I'm pleased today to introduce IRA
Katznelson welcome well thank you again
for the generous and gracious
introduction and for joining with bill
frocked of Yale University Press to
issue the invitation that brought me to
this podium there's a particular honor
that comes with delivering the Stimson
lectures the honor is compounded by the
really daunting list of prior speakers
who include Samuel Huntington and
Michael Walzer John Donne and Thomas
Schelling Susan Dunn David May who each
of whom is for me an intellectual
inspiration the chance to speak at Yale
about this topic is a particular
privilege in the late 1940s and early
1950s and again after 9/11 seminal work
was
at this university about national
security emergencies and exceptions
significant examples include Harold
Lasswell anxiety charged 1950 book
national security and individual freedom
and Bruce Ackerman's controversial 2004
proposals for an emergency Constitution
both of which ask us to consider without
innocence how to fortify national
security and safeguard Liberty during a
period marked by what Ackerman called
the normalization of emergency
conditions such interventions have been
concerned to understand whether and how
liberal democracies can grapple
effectively with security while
defending and successfully pinning down
an elusive constitutional integrity you
will have discovered you've heard from
my friend Ian that my three lecturers
are called Dolls nightmare liberalism's
edges and navigating the rule of law in
more mundane terms this evening I want
to pose the problem tomorrow search for
resources within the long liberal
tradition and close on Thursday with
tentative proposals for how we might
proceed in all I want to ask whether is
it whether it is possible to shield
individual and public rights and more
broadly guard the rule of law while
protecting citizens against foes who
threatened to defeat displace or distort
liberal democracy this conundrum has
been present since the earliest days of
anglo-american liberalism many things
there are wrote John Locke and the
Second Treatise in Chapter 14 on
prerogative
which the law can by no means provide
for and those must necessarily be left
to the discretion of him that has the
executive power in his hands to be
ordered by him as the public good an
advantage shall require without the
prescription of the law and sometimes
even against it end quote a century
later as he attempted to persuade New
York voters to ratify the constitution
of 1787 Alexander Hamilton averred in
Federalist 23 and I quote that the
circumstances that endanger the safety
of Nations are infinite and for this
reason no constitutional shackles can
wisely be imposed on the power to which
the care of it is committed the means of
security echoed James Madison in
Federalist 41 can only be regulated by
the means and danger of attack they will
in fact be ever determined by these
rules and by no others it is vain he
wrote to impose constitutional barriers
to the impulse of self-preservation in
the mid nineteenth century John Stuart
Mill announced I am far from condemning
in many case re I am far from condemning
in cases of extreme necessity the
assumption of absolute power in the form
of a temporary dictatorship in 1793
Robespierre asked his revolutionary
government which must move forward with
more energy and act with more freedom
than ordinary government less fair and
legitimate no he replied for it is
founded on the most sacred of laws the
people's salvation and on the most
unquestionable of entitlements necessity
from a revolutionary at the height of
the terror not a surprise
but for liberals against the law no
constitutional shackles vain to impose
constitutional barriers dictatorship the
predicament is not new and it cannot be
evaded no modern state certainly not the
United States can escape the exigencies
of security even at the founding
Hamilton underscored the prospects of
harm in Federalist 24 quote a wide ocean
separates the United States from Europe
he wrote yet there are various
considerations that warn us against an
excess of confidence even then in a
world with vastly slower transport
tenuous means of communication fewer
means of mobilization and dramatically
less lethal weapons than we know in
security beckoned quote Hamilton on one
side of us and stretching far into the
rear our growing settlements subject to
the Dominion of Britain on the other
side and extending to meet the British
settlements or colonies and
establishments subject to the domain of
Spain this situation and the vicinity of
the West India Islands belonging to
these two powers create between them in
respect to their American possessions
and in relation to us a common interest
the savage tribes on our western
frontier ought to be regarded as our
natural enemies their natural allies
because they have most to fear from us
and most to hope from them he concluded
by warning that quote these
circumstances combined admonish us not
to be sanguine in considering ourselves
as out of the reach of danger then as
Hamilton wrote and now as we continue to
live with nearly inexhaustible security
threats the challenge of exigencies
compels attention especially for Liberal
Democrats as
and cautioned in Federalist eight safety
from external dangers is the most
powerful director of human conduct even
the most ardent love of Liberty will
after time give way to its dictates if
the K if his counsel not to be too
sanguine was persuasive in the early
republic how much more so alas for us in
our time certainly my lifetime has been
marked by jarring insecurity with my
classmates as a child in Brooklyn during
the war in Korea I had to wear a metal
army dog tail an army style dog tag I've
viscerally recalled the quite terrifying
weekly duct and cover primary school
drills when we practice crouching below
our wooden desks under the aegis of the
federal civil defense administration
after 9/11 my family and I had to
confront the smell of death conveyed to
Manhattan's Upper West Side by a
northern wind from the World Trade
Center and who can forget the acres of
walls and fences covered by posters with
photographs of the missing insecurity
compounded even a soul as sober as Bruce
Ackerman could project in 2004 a future
marked by recurring terrorist assaults
on American soil
leading to legally sanctioned roundups
of tens of thousands whose religious
and/or national background would be
understood to suggest a significant
probability of subversive disloyalty
that's in his essay on emergency
Constitution we are enclosed in
fearfulness badly in need of sober
rationality and democratic reason in
this context I feel particularly
privileged to test my ideas here in what
I think of as the house of dal for my
remarks are motivated by a short article
only six pages long possibly the
shortest ever penned by Robert Dahl
called atomic energy and the democratic
process that he published in November
1953 ten months after Dwight Eisenhower
had been inaugurated for his first term
and just as Dahl and Ed Lindblom were
publishing their politics economics and
Welfare that book insisted that the
choice of particular social techniques
within public affairs must advance key
enlightenment values these they
specified in liberal terms and I quote
as freedom rationality and appropriate
inclusion plus security on his own and
with Lindblom Dahl was a member of a
heterogeneous and loosely coupled
impulse
I once designated as the political
studies enlightenment across a range of
types of social knowledge not just doll
and Lindblom but Hannah Arendt and Karl
Polanyi David Truman and Richard
Hofstadter Harold Lasswell and David
Riesman treated social science in the
postwar years entwined with analytical
history as a pathway to ethics and they
insisted that the tradition of
enlightenment required a new realism a
good deal of repair and much
fortification after their generations
shocking experiences of total war
totalitarianism and holocaust they
insisted on critical adjustments to
thicken liberal democracies capacities
deepen its realism and strengthened its
defenses against evil all the while
rejecting the sense that Enlightenment
liberalism is unable to defend human
freedom or worse that itself it is the
main source responsible for profound
depredation anti-liberal disparagement
on the right in the spirit of Carl
Schmitt
or on the left in the spirit of Max
Horkheimer ante or door Adorno was
opposed by this group who feared
undermining their most cherished
political values they took
representative democracies critics
seriously but refused to be seduced by
anti-liberal blandishments this legacy
Orient's my remarks a quest for realism
repair and fortification all the while
understanding that nothing nothing is
guaranteed two years before dwight
eisenhower's january twentieth 1953
inauguration doll published a 115 page
report with Ralph Brown jr. a colleague
here at the law school called the
domestic control of atomic energy
written for the Social Science Research
Council Committee on the social
implications of atomic energy that
extended essay closed with a series of
quote problems of general theoretical
significance
these included the effects of secrecy on
the democratic process the relationship
of lay citizens to experts and I quote
the role of leaders in making decisions
in American democracy doll and brown
asked whether and how the leaders in
this substantive arena could be quote
controlled by traditional democratic
institutions and they were concerned to
identify effective limits to their
discretion these questions remain
pressing in the preface to the Dahle
Brown report SSRC President Pendleton
Haring a distinguished political
scientist observed that its orientation
was quote informed and matter-of-fact
rather than written in a tone of fateful
alarm but it was just such apocalyptic
language that characterized President
Eisenhower's inaugural at the East Front
the capital in January 1953 the promise
of this life he observed is imperiled by
the very genius that has made it
possible science seems ready to confer
upon us as its final gift the power to
erase human life from this planet
three months later Eisenhower spoke of
quote the point of peril following eight
years of fear and force what can the
world or any nation in it hope for he
asked if no turning is found on this
dread Road the worst to be feared and
the best to be expected he said can be
simply stated the worst is atomic war
the best would be this a life of
perpetual fear and tension this was
Ike's nightmare perpetual fear and
tension the most basic exigency had
intensified and the amplification had
become eternal at that very moment Bob
Dole was curating a special issue of the
annals of the American Academy of
political and social science dedicated
to the impact of atomic energy a special
issue that sought to assess whether it
could be possible and I quote to deal
with atomic energy through democratic
political processes noting approvingly
that the arrival of nuclear weapons had
it not pushed us to the edge of
dictatorship and perceiving how
America's leaders quote are quite
patently not imposing a tyrannical will
on a terrified public he nonetheless
discerned in this policy area and I
quote that the political processes of
democracy do not operate effectively
atomic policy his epigrammatic article
concluded will remain the product of
only a tiny group of leaders in all the
choices on offer which quote defy wide
popular understand
and control had become a kind of
indigestible element in the operation of
American democratic politics and quote
an indigestible element in the operation
of American democratic politics here lay
dolls nightmare three years later the
University of Chicago sociologist Edward
sills assayed the country's security
policies noting that quote every strain
of the post-war world has been
accentuated by the atomic bomb he was
concerned for what he called the torment
of secrecy in which secrecy is both
privacy made compulsory and
paradoxically the enemy of privacy for
an order for secrets to be safeguarded
he wrote privacy must be invaded secrecy
he conceded may be necessary for the
preservation of liberal democracy in an
atomic age but there is the persisting
danger of a gsella tree of secrecy and a
gsella tree of tests of loyalty and
shills particularly worried seven
decades ago about how liberal democracy
in responding to real threats can
exhibit hyper patriotism xenophobia
isolationism fundamentalism and the ugly
side of populism that was shills in the
1950s Americans long ago had assumed
that emergencies in this pub arena of
public life and policy could be managed
by temporary instruments but doll and
shills made the point that no longer
indeed Eisenhower joined in that thought
no longer and not ever again this of
course also was the moment when doll was
thinking hard about what soon would
become a preface to democratic theory
which immediately was hailed as a
landmark when published in 1956
yet in his largely forgotten atomic
energy and the democratic process Dahl
concomitant Lee was identifying a
distinct regime dimension that not only
stood apart from what he designated as
America's polyarchy but threatened to
expand atomic energy he wrote aptly
symbolizes an era in which opportunities
for popular control have generally
dwindled
perhaps he ruminated this unusual extent
of a leap control might prove to be no
more than a passing adjustment to a
novel situation by an essentially
vigorous and healthy democracy but he
closed however on a dystopian note the
articles final sentence refers quote to
a growing class of situations for which
the traditional democratic processes are
rather unsuitable and for which
traditional theories of democracy
provide no rational answer Dahl returned
to this theme in the Frank Abrams
lectures he delivered at Syracuse
University in 1980 for talks he called
controlling nuclear weapons democracy
versus guardianship what was to be done
he is stringently inquired about what he
designated as quote this is now thirty
years after the the first article what
he designated as a strategic paradox no
decisions he wrote can be more fateful
for Americans than decisions about
nuclear weapons yet these decisions have
largely escaped the control of the
democratic process what indeed should be
done with what intellectual resources
and with which policy possibilities
dolls nightmare of relentless emergency
and expanding exceptions implicitly
tendered and elegy for simpler times
when emergencies and the exceptions that
evoked emergencies of war or economic
crisis
and exceptions marked by an unusual
degree of executive power possessed or
at least appeared to possess a beginning
a middle and an end inside such
circumstances institutional responses
like that of ancient Rome's temporary
dictatorship could be geared above all
to sustain the rule of law
ever since that institution the Roman
institution was rediscovered and valued
by Machiavelli as an instrument of
rescue and preservation at times of
peril the Roman model has served more
than any other as the archetype of means
with which politics can weather dire
circumstances including civil strife and
invasion by temporarily suspending
procedures and by concentrating
effective power in a ruler without
unduly compromising the rule of law
quote everyman the least conversant in
the Roman story Hamilton wrote in
Federalist 70 knows how often that
Republic was obliged to take refuge in
the absolute power of a single man under
the formidable title of dictator but
unlike violent and unjust tyrants as
andreas Khalifa's has underscored the
dictator denoted a legal and regular if
extraordinary magistracy intended to
protect the public good in moments of
crisis and danger and as the entry in
the 1931 encyclopedia of the social
sciences records quote as significant as
the absoluteness of the roman
dictatorship was the fact that it was
temporary bernard menon has underlined
how in coping with emergencies liberals
long have thought that liberty may be
restricted only for the sake of liberty
not just for the sake of just any kind
of common good here lay the appeal of
the roman model until the mid 20th
century liberal thinkers and
Maker's shared in the premise that
crises are marked by a beginning and an
end with emergency powers limited in
time and content security measures
including constitutional dictatorship
could be made compatible with core
liberal values especially the rule of
law until the mid 20th century this
impermanent model was central to
virtually all treatments of emergencies
and exceptions within the liberal
political tradition because the Roman
example was located inside the law with
the purpose of protecting not replacing
or surmounting the Constitution for this
reason it won the approbation of them of
the most important 20th century thinkers
about emergency powers including in the
United States called Friedrich Frederick
Watkins from Yale and Clinton Clinton
Rossiter each of whom crafted a response
to democracy's anti liberal critics not
by chance is more than half of the
opening in Rossiter 'he's landmark 1948
book constitutional dictatorship devoted
to the roman dictatorship a practice
that spanned the period from 501 to 202
BC this regard was grounded in empirical
realities in the United States Woodrow
Wilson was the first president to issue
a national emergency Proclamation but it
was revoked by statute once World War
one concluded
unlike Lincoln who often had confronted
his crisis by displacing the
prerogatives of Congress
Wilson proceeded primarily by eliciting
legislative authorizations during the
war Congress delegated vast powers over
transportation the Shipping Act of 1916
arms production the National Defense Act
of 1916 private property the army
Appropriations Act of 1916
Manufacturing and the distribution of
net war necessities the lever Act 1917
and emergency powers to coordinate the
federal government the Overman Act 1918
yet as the war closed and the crisis
ended the Wilson administration
dismantled the mobilization
institutional machinery and wartime
dictatorial authorities the nation's
government the political scientist
Lindsay Rogers observed in 1934 took off
its war harness very quickly the 1918
Sedition Act banning criticism of the
government including negative
commitments about the military the
Constitution or the flag was repealed by
Congress in 1921 yet the 1917 Espionage
Act authorizing the Postmaster General
to remove treasonable or seditious
material from the mail and providing
penalties of up to 20 years imprisonment
for those convicted of interfering with
military recruitment remains on the
books a harbinger of the later
post-world War two
shift from impermanent emergencies to
enduring exceptions for Clinton Rossiter
writing in the 1940s the Roman
institution remained valuable quote as a
theoretical standard as a sort of moral
yardstick against which to measure
modern institutions of constitutional
dictatorship similarly in his post 911
emergency Constitution Ackerman
considered the Roman model quote as an
inspiration for my heavy reliance on a
political system of checks and balances
in all cases there was a rigid rule on
quoting Ackerman the appointing official
could not select himself as a
consequence the consuls had every
incentive to resist the call for a
dictatorship unless it was really
necessary
there was a second basic limitation
dictators were limited to six months
in office the term was not renewable
under any circumstances about 90
dictators were named during the 300 year
history of the office but none violated
that rule and no dictator used his
extraordinary powers to name another
dictator at the end of the term
Ackerman's summary replicated the
criteria that Algernon Sidney advocated
in 1680 in his text discourses
concerning government for which he was
beheaded three years later
roans dictatorship had served Sidney
underscored as quote a commission
grounded in the will of the people to
ultimately uphold Liberty I do therefore
grant he wrote that a power like to the
dictatorial limited in time
circumscribed by law and kept
perpetually under the supreme authority
of the people may by virtuous and well
disciplined nations upon some occasions
be prudently granted to a virtuous man a
situation he distinguished and I quote
from that of our monarch whose power is
in himself
subject to no law that sentence that
cost Sidney his head limited in time
circumscribed by law kept perpetually
under the supreme authority of the
people these were precisely the
qualities that Robert dolls realistic
nightmare designated as having become
obsolete by the early 1950s the world of
exigency in the globe's leading liberal
democracy no longer was limited in time
no longer circumscribed by ordinary
lawful processes no longer under the
authority of the people impermanent
emergencies had yielded to an expanding
zone of enduring exceptions this
transformation and conditions did not
occur all at once of course after World
War one
and following a period of intense
constitutional dictatorship normal
procedures had been completely restored
not only in this country but in Britain
and France but no longer the 1944 cast
of Harold Lasswell that quote we are
moving toward a world of garrison States
seemed confirmed including in the
globe's leading liberal democracy for
developments in the 1940s had generated
danger without end and with that a deep
sense of anxiety a remarkable
intensification of violence above all by
the invention and use of atomic weapons
and the tandem vulnerability of
civilians the persistence of a
totalitarian enemy America's new
international status as the leader and
protective protector of half the globe
that placed burdens and shaped new
threats and with the Cold War an
inability to determine when conditions
of emergency might close doll was not
alone in designating these sources of
apprehension his brief atomic energy
article captured more widespread concern
Cornell's Robert Cushman devoted his
1944 American Political Science
Association presidential address to
civil liberty after the war he warned
that the conclusion of the conflict
would not end the country's state of
emergency because quote the
constitutional democracies of the world
without precedent are fighting for their
lives against powers which are not
seeking merely to conquer them but which
are bent upon destroying constitutional
democracy as a system of government and
replacing it by a brutal totalitarianism
from Princeton the legal scholar Edward
Corwin detailed in total war and the
Constitution a 1948 book how each of the
main pillars of American constitutional
law dual federalism
the separation of powers judicial review
had been quote expel
from the field of Foreign Relations by
broad presidential prerogative powers
buttress by dramatic acts of
congressional delegation what is unclear
Corwin opined was whether the core
constitutional idea of Liberty against
government could survive near the close
of constitutional dictatorship also
published in 1948 Rossiter emphasized
how as in Rome no constitutional
dictatorship should extend beyond the
termination of the crisis for which it
was instituted but against the dominant
grain of his own book he acknowledged
that this approach might no longer be
possible quote dismal and distressing as
our prospect may be it seems probable
that in the years to come the American
people will be faced with more rather
than fewer national emergencies
additionally he wrote in the books
penultimate paragraph the bomb has
settled once and for all the question
whether the United States can go back to
being a negative state from now on the
extent accent will be on power not
limitation following up Rossiter soon
wrote a series of apprehensive articles
to the point of ruminating about how the
United States might be governed during
and after an atomic war and what might
be done with the White House and
Congress in ruins and here at Yale
Harold Lasswell was considering in his
1950 volume national security and
individual freedom the implications of
what nine years earlier he had labeled
the garrison state dominated by
specialists in violence devoted to
asking whether and how such a state
could be adequately managed the book
opens with a statement of quote the
central problem which it designated as
how to maintain a proper balance between
national security and individual freedom
in a continuing crisis of national
defense
a puzzle he noted lacking in any options
for a crisp resolution the combination
of Cold War and atomic weapons induced
Congress to fashion new delegations
producing what in 1949 the presidential
scholar Albert Sturm was identifying as
quote a cornucopia of new legal
authority to the chief executive the
result was a situation in which
increasingly authority to cope with
persisting emergencies was placed in the
hands of the president and the president
alone
unlike Rome's dictators who neither
could announce nor extend a period of
exception America's presidents began to
amass unprecedented capacities to
enhance national security and whereas
earlier grants of this kind like the
emergency price Control Act of 1942 and
the war labor disputes Act of 1943
possessed termination dates
many of the new delegations contained no
sunset provisions after the war only
some of the president's wartime powers
were recaptured and it quickly became
clear as sturm observed the time that
quote many laws will remain on the
statute books permanently to provide a
reserve for future exceeds the first
example of such enduring legislation was
the Atomic Energy Act of 1946 for the
development and control of atomic energy
in the aftermath of her Oshima and
nagasaki that statute placed all
efficient able material domestic as well
as military in the hands of the
president and the Atomic Energy
Commission of five members he would
appoint no private patents could be
permitted quote provision after
provision complained Clare Boothe Luce
than a Republican congresswoman from
Connecticut muzzles free competition and
depresses incentive and product
in all mining industrial patent and
invention fields which impinge at any
point on the manufacturer of nuclear
energy and quote yet even for most
market oriented conservatives this
legislation gained the status of a
necessary exception the bill is full of
provisions noted senator Eugene Milliken
of Colorado with which I could not
subscribe in any other connection the
zone of exception continued to expand
the 1949 amendments to the National
Security Act of 1947 exempted the
Central Intelligence Agency from
ordinary reporting responsibilities to
Congress for its expenditures and
activities concerned with subversion the
Internal Security Act of 1950 created a
group of citizens to be treated
distinctively with regard to their
freedom of association and speech by
making it illegal to fail to disclose
membership in a communist organization
when working for the government and
unlawful to contribute funds to such
organizations to apply for renew or use
a passport and broadcast or use the
media without an explicit acknowledgment
of communist affiliation the law
required all Communists and communist
front organizations to register with the
federal government and it established
the subversive activities control board
to enforce the Act quote our
Constitution is not so weak the bill's
sponsor Senator Pat McCarran Nevada
Democrat insisted that it denies us the
power and authority to safeguard it once
protected speech was relabeled sedition
once protected silence became mandatory
speech two years later in 1952 the most
secret and far-reaching component of the
US intelligence apparatus the National
Security Agency came into being as the
permanent successor to the armed forces
security agency
that had been formed three years earlier
initially under the Joint Chiefs of
Staff to coordinate the electronic and
communications intelligence activities
of the Army Security Agency the National
Suit naval security group and the Air
Force Security Service that first
incarnation had modest capacity and soon
was judged to be ineffective in a
classified June 1952 authorizing letter
President Harry Truman called for
establishing the NSA four months later
it's fun its founding was carried out by
means of a revised National Security
Council intelligence directive nothing
to do with Congress whatsoever and in
1953 in United States v Reynolds the
Supreme Court created the analytical
framework for a state secrets privilege
permitting the federal government to
prevent the disclosure of information
that it believes could harm the security
of the United States so began a long
history now extending more than seven
decades of law making an executive
decision for permanent exceptions
regarding atomic weapons geopolitics
internal as well as external security by
Proclamation or delegation power has
been centralized in the executive
Congress has assumed only limited
oversight courts in the main have been
bypassed the number of persons involved
in making key decisions has been sharply
restricted so too has open debate and
transparency citizens become more
visible to government through
surveillance in turn the nation's
security situation became less evident
to citizens through secrecy and the
absence of disclosure
moreover emergency laws tended to become
baselines for new laws and new emergency
declarations as future threats developed
notably in the present century when
associated with the Menace of terror
America's debacle in Vietnam generated
pushback the War Powers Resolution of
1973 passed over the veto of President
Nixon required the Armed Forces only be
placed in combat by a congressional
declaration of war or by statutory
authorization or by the president in a
national emergency created by attack
upon the United States the territories
or possessions or its armed forces
further the president must notify
Congress within 48 hours of committing
armed forces to action and any
deployment beyond 60 days is forbidden
without a congressional authorization of
military force an AUMF or a
congressional declaration of war that
periods renewal of legislative capacity
also included the national emergencies
act of 1976 that terminated
long-standing declared emergencies
including the one that had been declared
by President Truman in 1950 at the start
of the Korean War were still in
existence in the mid 1970s the law
insisted the 1976 law insisted that
future declarations be limited in time
and it offered means for Congress to
negate executive declarations by way of
a majority vote legislative veto and the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act of
1978 FISA provided procedures for
judicial and congressional oversight
over foreign intelligence surveillance
most notably it created the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court to hold
closed ex-parte sessions to consider
issuing warrants though initially passed
to provide checks and limits FISA later
became an instrument authorizing
extensive indeed unprecedented patterns
of surveillance what seemed like a
restraining measure holding executive
action back under the rule of law became
an enabling authorization for
unrestrained action a non-trivial
warning that legality does not
necessarily sustain the rule of law the
counter moment passed in 1983 the
Supreme Court found the legislative veto
to be unconstitutional thus the current
president the United States will have
the option to veto any congressional
legislation passed to invalidate his
recent declaration of emergency at the
close of his presidency Ronald Reagan's
executive order 12333 means assistance
for law enforcement act that authorized
national state and local police to
conduct electronic surveillance by
requiring that telecommunications
companies and manufacturers of equipment
facilitate these activities no fewer
than twenty three targeted executive
declarations of emergency were
promulgated in the quarter century
before the terror attacks of 9/11 these
actions increasingly rooted in statutory
law the Congressional Research Service
reported in 1990 permitted presidents to
seize property organize and control the
means of production assign military
forces abroad Institute martial law and
oversee all transportation and
communication regulate the operation of
private enterprise restrict travel and
in a variety of ways control the lives
of US citizens ever since the 2001
attacks on the World Trade Center and
the Pentagon the United States has
continues to be under President Bush's
September 14 declaration of national
emergency by reason of certain terrorist
attacks soon followed on September 23rd
by an emergency order quote blocking
property and prohibiting transactions
with persons who commit threatened to
commit or support terrorism subsequently
a massive array of instruments of
surveillance and security have been
deployed through statutes and orders by
presidents Bush Obama and Trump as Judge
Richard Posner noted in 2006
counter-terrorist measures then already
included and I quote the attempt to deny
the right of habeas corpus to captured
terrorist suspects the interception of
phone calls and other electronic
communications such as emails of US
citizens by the National Security Agency
outside the limits set by the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act ambitious
data mining projects such as the
military's able danger project demands
by the FBI under Section 2015 of the
Patriot Act for records of library
borrowings monitoring of the
constitutionally protected speech of
radical iman's torture or quasi torture
of terrorist suspects including US
citizens apprehended in the United
States rather than on a foreign field of
control such as Afghanistan or Iraq
these exceptions were announced an
executive orders on detention 2001
habeas corpus 2001 terror detainee legal
status 2002 lawful interrogation 2009
applicability of criminal law 2010 the
periodic review of detainees 2011 border
security and immigration enforcement
2017
protecting the nation from foreign
terrorists entry into the United States
2017 and protecting America through
lawful detention of terrorists 2018
at a time when partisan polarization is
widely thought to be the cause of
reduced legislative productivity
Congress has been uncommon ly active in
passing among other laws the Patriot Act
2001 the Homeland Security Act 2002 the
intelligence reform and Prevention of
Security Act 2004 that protect America
Act 2007 the FISA Amendments Act 2008
the Patriot extension Act 2011 and the
USA Freedom Act 2015 other instruments
of exception have been promulgated
without Proclamation or legislation
perhaps most notable was the secret
authorization by President Bush
permitting the National Security Agency
to eavesdrop on telephone conversations
within the United States on Americans
and others inside the country without
court approved warrants in what NSA
called a special collections program
once begun there was almost an overnight
and sorry there was almost no oversight
outside the NSA as the agency could pick
targets not only without courts
certification but without agreement by
the Department of Justice or other parts
of the administration these policies
cumulatively narrowed legislative power
widened executive prerogative and
limited the secure range of rights
possessed by citizens and foreign
persons clearly conditions of exception
have become wider and scope more
heterogeneous in character evermore
routine within a week of the attacks
Congress authorized President Bush in an
uncommon Lee broad delegation to quote
use all necessary and appropriate force
against those nations organizations or
persons he determines planned authorized
committed or aided the terrorist attacks
that occurred on September 11 2001 or
harbored such organizations or persons
in order to prevent any future acts of
international terrorism against the
United States by such nations
organizations or
further President Bush's in-house lawyer
John you insisted that this
authorization had been superfluous
he wrote the power to initiate military
hostilities particularly in response to
the threat of an armed attack rests
exclusively with the president without
any limits on the executives judgment
whether they use military force in
response to the national emergency
President Obama did not base his actions
on this unitary executive approach
allowing presidents alone to determine
when national emergencies exist and how
to respond with force surveillance
torture unlimited detention or military
tribunals and whether to set aside laws
such as criminal codes in an open-ended
manner by contrast to the prior
administration the Obama administration
approach was more minimal in its
orientation to war powers calling often
for the end of conflict authorized by
the broad 2001 authorization for the use
of military force the Obama
administration favored statutory instead
of broad constitutional arguments and
offered elaborate and often transparent
explanations of its policies and
decisions from the initial day of the
administration had pushed back against
the treatment of detainees beyond the
scope of the US Army Field Manual and
international law making the closing of
Guantanamo a signal objective a goal we
all know that it failed to achieve yet
while relating oh I will sorry while
relying more on expansive processes for
decisions and more on congressional
authorization and delegation the Obama
years also advanced bulk data collection
a unilateral use of force in Libya
without international or domestic legal
warrants and the targeted killing in
Yemen of an American citizen Anwar
al-awlaki who was promoting terrorism to
be sure that was carried out by a drone
strike in September 2011
each of which represented expansions of
presidential discretion in all noted
Curtis Bradley and Jack Goldsmith at the
close of the Obama presidency the AUMF
remained the principle legal foundation
under US domestic law for the president
to use force against and detain members
of terrorist organizations especially
after its presidential extension in 2014
to cover the use of military force
against the Islamic state even with a
self-conscious attempt to establish
restraint together with policies
narrowly focused on operational
objectives none of the extensive legal
entitlements protected and projected by
the Bush administration were explicitly
renounced and thus have remained ready
for use by the Trump administration and
now in closing let me simply note that
since his inauguration President Trump
has returned to the unitary executive
view making uncompromising claims for
his authority rejecting any kind of
executive limitation at a minimum call
Friedreich's designation of regularized
restraint as the centerpiece of the
liberal rule of law has been called into
question and the AUMF which began in
2001 as giving authority to use force
against al-qaeda in Afghanistan has
become a protein foundation for the
indefinite war wrote these commentators
against an assortment of terrorist
organizations in numerous countries a
development Bradley in Goldsmith
designated as one of the most remarkable
legal developments in American public
law dolls nightmare in short has
expanded and intensified might it be
tamed tomorrow and Thursday I should
like to probe that challenge by
amplifying dolls alarmed observations in
the dimensions of theory and history
regarding history I will argue that the
dilemma
he and others identified in the 1950s
were composed not only by new
circumstances in place following World
War two and by subsequent decisions
about national security but also by the
accrual of experiences ideas and
institutions that had developed at
earlier critical junctures and that
shaped the repertoire of liberal
responses to exigencies tomorrow evening
I will endeavor to discern resources
from John Locke to the recent past
within and at the edges of the liberal
tradition as means to help identify
norms and policy ideas that might help
navigate exigencies within the rule of
law notwithstanding the shift from
impermanent emergencies to enduring
exceptions during my closing lecture on
Thursday I will turn to current tasks of
normative and institutional creativity
but first tomorrow I will focus on two
earlier points of inflection the moment
of 17th and 18th century state formation
that culminated on these shores with
America's founding and the late 19th and
early 20th century epoch characterized
by the rise of mass democracy and
industrial capitalism expanding colonial
empires and World War at those moments
debates and decisions about exigencies
fashioned a repertoire with in the
anglo-american liberal tradition on
which dolls generation and ours have
drawn I will be arguing that after the
shift from impermanent emergencies to
enduring exceptions these ideas to guide
policy remain indispensable but they are
also inadequate indispensable because
they offer a repertoire from which we
can draw but inadequate because they
rest on suppositions that no longer
obtain to reframe the question how can
we renew and adapt the best features of
this liberal lineage
to serve our more difficult present
conditions thank you reflect on and
anticipate what's coming and we're going
to open things up for conversation with
the audience we have about 25 minutes
but I thought I would exercise the
prerogative of the chair and start the
conversation by inviting you to say a
little bit more about the institutional
the greatest fear was that the
legislature particularly the House of
Representatives was going to be too
powerful and nobody was worrying about
the power of the executive and we live
in a very different wall of course today
where for instance we now have huge
changes standing army with the
commander-in-chief which almost by
itself sucks power into the legislature
we have that much more independent
election of the president which gives
the president much more independent
legitimacy and authority these are be
the legislature than was the case in the
18th century but we also have some some
issues in in the logic of the separation
of powers you talked about dollars he
pointed out in preface democratic theory
that the the ambition will be made to
counteract ambition was sort of long on
rhetoric and short on mechanisms for
actually making it work and others have
observed the same things on marriage on
the scale said you know that if you
think about these institutions
counteracting one another well the
presidency doesn't
internal collective action challenges
whereas now 400 and 535 representatives
that we kind of both houses of congress
has huge conflicting in incentives it's
as much harder for them to coordinate
and then you also have things like the
as you mentioned the unitary theory of
the executive which has been welcomed by
the younger Posner among others and John
you and people like that so a lot of
that tells the story of the sort of
decreasing capacity of Congress to
resist paragraphs from the executive or
just the natural evolution of things
that has strengthened the executive but
it's a more complicated story than that
as you yourself argue a considerable
length in the chapters on the Truman
administration in fear itself what that
was and you you briefly alluded to it
again here it wasn't a case of the
Roosevelt and then Truman
administration's making power grabs that
Congress found itself unable to stop on
the contrary Congress was just shoveling
over Authority including fiscal
authority and authority to take the CIA
off budget and what are these things
they were they were actively
surrendering it wasn't that they were
failing to stop and then all of the just
this litany of post 9/11 the vast
majority of it again was legislation
Congress actively actively engaging in
its in its own evisceration or its
institutional evisceration so how do you
think about this the push in the poll if
you like of this story that you're
telling you and what if what if what
should we take about away from that
about the basic theory of the separation
of powers as its played out in the last
period that's that's an enormous
question I'm a I'm pleased to say that
this theme which includes the question
of incentives for members of Congress to
behave in this way or that way will be
something I will come back to in the
next different parts of the next two
lectures the there are a number of
really interesting puzzles you'll see
that those who hear tomorrow's lecture
will will hear a discussion which in an
area of history where I'm something of a
country boy Lincoln and the Civil War in
which we'll take up the question of how
Lincoln behaved with extraordinary
executive power
there was an 11 week period in which
Congress didn't even meet in which he
raised an army went to war and so on but
how he took great care to respect the
separation of powers after
retrospectively and I think one of the
there's a micro puzzle for us and a
larger sort of macro puzzle or maybe
also a meso middle level puzzle the
micro puzzle is one of that you raised
Ian's about incentives its most members
of Congress certainly today do not want
to be seen in any way as potentially
weak on security and the the vast amount
of delegations that they voted for with
huge votes across party lines in an era
of polarization in part reflect that the
the larger mega question the macro
question is one that's been with us far
longer you find it in laws the Locke's
discussion of prerogative power in
circumstances that the man urgent action
security circumstances
who can act but the executive that's why
all those comments near the beginning of
my talk from not just locked but
Hamilton and Madison and that remember
the Federalist Papers are those essays
were written to sell the Constitution
they were written to persuade the
American people that were not going to
create a government that's rapacious
that's endlessly unlimited but they were
honest enough to say that in this area
constitutional shackles may not hold and
maybe they shouldn't even at times so
it's it's a hard-baked macro problem and
to use a i'll come back to a term our
colleague stevens quranic and karen Oren
of use of inter currents of how
decisions taken at different moments
about the separation of powers
concatenate not always neatly in a
linear development way to create
configurations of institutional elements
at a kind of middle level that both
shape and constrain the kinds of
decisions political actors are taking
last sentence for now I'm if I someone
stood graduate student asked me recently
in one word how would you describe what
you are well it's not easy to answer as
a political scientist and I said an
institutionalist and the because
institutions are con juries of rules
both formal and informal which are
incentives and disincentives to behavior
and therefore help establish
probabilities and the question we face
collectively not as social scientists
simply but as citizens is how in this
vexing area that doll was one of the
first to see was shifting from temporary
impermanent emergencies to permanent
enduring exceptions how do we as
citizens begin to imagine shaping an
institutional arena that can deliver
security
but not salami like as it were
eliminate the liberties for which that
security is the is devoted and hence
that's where I want to turn the next two
times any questions brief question but
it's probably not gonna be a brief
answer but in terms of the development
of ex engine season into the mind I'm
sorry impermanent emergencies
where and when is a mechanism developed
to determine the difference between
what's an exigency or impermanent
emergency and just simply a management
issue that has to be maintained over
time good question well let me just I
should have gone just to maybe even
defining my terms an exigency it's an
old-fashioned word I it was Hamilton I
quoted who was using it is it's a
description an exigency is a descriptive
term about danger we live in a world of
exigencies that Hamilton we have British
and Spanish enemies Native American
enemies who are gonna line up with them
more than us because we're we're gonna
give them no good and so on and so forth
an emergency in the language among
others of Locke refers to the within
that larger frame of exigency to a
sudden and something often unforeseen
acceleration of insecurity bombs drop on
Pearl Harbor if it had been entirely
foreseen the fleet wouldn't have been in
the sitting ducks 2001 9/11 again you
have something happens that
boom transforms circumstances and you
need a response by exceptions
I mean establishing a framework this is
the dahle insight which is to the side
of not entirely outside of but to the
side of ordinary democratic processes
and what I simply in this descriptive
mostly descriptive first lecture wanted
to show is that how dolls and
Eisenhower's and chills --is and
Corwin's and others worries from between
the 1940s to mid-1950s in fact not only
their their their anxiety not only was
redeemed in the actually but to a scale
they didn't imagine and the that does
not mean that I think that all responses
to insecurity since the 1950s have been
deliberately undertaken to hollow out
liberal democracy I don't believe that
believe most were undertaken or to
protect liberal democracy but the
consequences are a really big question
which I also hope to grapple with a bit
how much of that can occur without
transforming the core features of
liberal democracy itself and at what
point do you move from the edge into the
center so it hasn't not quite an answer
to your question but I think it's I want
to begin by at least thinking about
these three words of exigency emergency
and exception and not treat them as
synonyms but as overlapping yet
distinctive and I think the challenge to
us is is how to deal with exigencies and
emergencies in circumstances where the
exceptions
have become hard baked into the
character of the regime and perhaps
necessarily salt we can debate that and
if so then how do we proceed and that's
what I'm trying to help myself think
about and would love to get your views
thank you
this is a little bit of a side question
maybe and I'm looking forward to hearing
your the discussion tomorrow especially
about the longer history of liberalism's
response to the problem of executive
overreach but I wondered in a way I just
a side question about what the citizens
imagination or duties and
responsibilities are facing this
situation so so one of the things I
think you know is interesting in the
history of thinking about dissent you
know a lot of the issues around dissent
does concern this this question of a
responsibility related to responsibility
as having some connection to people's
sense of being involved in the decision
making process so one of the things that
gdh cole wrote around the time the
League of Nations and thinking about new
types of federal sovereignties was that
you know he was arguing as a pluralist
and in a row so Ian sort of way said you
know in those situations like foreign
policy where citizens feel like they
have the least direct impact they also
might feel and I think for him they have
the least duty of obedience as well so
there was some so I was just curious
thinking about what that you know what
that what's how to think about a
citizen's obligation to the states in
that sense when decision-making feels
separated and on the flip side I guess
you know it can in our contemporary
moment it's often said that you know
people are willing clearly to pay for a
more extreme standing army or to - for
protection and security and support this
legislation but they would be unwilling
or people say this I'm curious about you
but they would be very unwilling to
abide by conscription or anything like
you know so I just was curious on the
other side of this you know questions of
citizen obligation or dissent that might
have some that might be also you know
there might be some tearing at the edges
there the the more executive power or
more of these things have no
institutional link or maybe even an
imaginative link to what citizens take
to be the things that need to be
protected or even if we know a larger
question of those who might argue also
you know the first you know I was
teaching this and thinking about the
ACLU was founded as part of the defense
of conscription again you know against I
would connected to the fellowship of
reconciliation and against conscription
in the First World War
so there is something about rethinking
the nature of civil liberties is so
closely tied to the demands and
obligations of wartime citizenry in some
form so it's a wonderful question there
you're asking put it in one or two
sentences whether they if there's a
hollowing out of procedures and ordinary
ways in which democratic liberal
democratic life comes to decision
through elections parties open debate
congressional lawmaking etc etc if
there's a large zone where that doesn't
happen to citizens continue to offer
both loyalty and obligation or a sense
to have a sense of obligation of course
there's a wonderful essay by Judas
clardy to score on loyalty and
obligation and in which she makes the
following distinction at least as I
understand that obligation she says is a
rational requirement loyalty is an
emotional question and so I would split
your puzzle into those two parts
what is the stand
different historical conditions of both
objectively and subjectively of the
sense of obligation and what is the
status mostly subjectively of the
meaning of loyalty and it's very
striking to me I don't have a guy don't
have a good answer to your question it's
I really want to think hard about it
that's so much of the tumult in America
at the very moment I made central to at
least the first half of this talk the
late 40s to the mid 50s
the the moment when dolls nightmare was
emerging as it were was all about
obligation and security the controlling
subversion loyalty and the Truman
administration initiated loyalty
investigations of every American civil
servant now to do that implies a certain
degree of insecurity about people's
loyalty and commitment and obligation
and that was at a moment when issues of
conscription were as a less charge than
they might be today though it's worth
recalling that in 1940 and 41 when
President Roosevelt proposed a peacetime
draft it was met with enormous pushback
enormous pushback and I like to say I
believe it's true the single most
important vote in the House of
Representatives in the twentieth century
now that's a fairly big claim was the
203 to 202 vote in the house in 1941 to
renew conscription from the 1940 act and
this is months before Pearl Harbor five
months before Pearl Harbor I think maybe
six months and the that vote pitted well
what that vote did was to remove
the restrictions of the 1940 Selective
Service Act which had barred the use of
any troops outside the Western
Hemisphere so isolationists could vote
for it and it also took away the
one-year character of the draft
Roosevelt says we need an army we can't
just end it now after one year and the
vote was 203 to 202 with almost every
Republican voting no on the grounds it's
a threat to Liberty we're at peace why
are we constricting people northern
Democrats who had Irish German and
Italian constituents tended to vote no
the italians and germans didn't want
their kids potentially fighting their
relatives and the those who had Irish
constituents didn't exactly want to go
to the defense of Great Britain at that
time and only because other northern
Democrats but unanimously Southern Jim
Groth Democrats ironically voted for
this conscription in the United States
at Pearl Harbor of anything like a
military otherwise the country would
have had a smaller military or as small
as Belgium's a footnote this is not the
only zone of exception and as it were in
the history of liberal democracy if we
think about the way the American
Philippines were governed or Puerto Rico
or wasn't go to the British case and so
on one sees lines of but those are lines
of not defending them but us in them
here the dolls puzzle nightmare
Eisenhower's nightmare was about the US
as it were the the internal and for that
the questions of loyalty and obligation
are quite fundamental thanks
maybe to thank you for this incredibly
provocative beginning I'm struck by the
way in which the story that you tell is
focused on exigencies that even if they
then redound to the way the United
States operates internally are focused
ultimately on something beyond its
borders and I'm thinking about this in
the context into some of your earlier
work which has emphasized the two phases
of the American State and so this makes
me wonder a little bit about the
relationship between the internal and
the external in the context of an
exigency and so maybe two two questions
to think over if we think about dolls
nightmare or the atomic bomb and the
threat that nuclear war would represent
as a kind of external exigency and the
ways in which the legislation that you
flag in the second half of the 20th
century is bound up with these external
threats where where are the internal
exigencies and do those have a similar
effect on American democracy so I think
about say emergencies that are declared
in the aftermath of a natural disaster
or an internal seditious threat that
isn't connected to something like the
threat of global communism so if we
think of those because there are
exigencies like that in American history
so one first question why aren't those
driving the story is there some
fundamental difference between
exigencies that emerge from this
external threat and the sort of internal
emergency and then and then the second
question is is is is about American
democracy itself and the effect these
exigencies might have on them so if we
think about something like an emergency
declaration in the aftermath of a
natural disaster do we have reason to
believe that that too presents the same
sort of threat to the elaboration of
liberal democracy as say the problem of
controlling nuclear weapons or is there
something about the the way the
democratic process itself works when it
comes to the International the foreign
the crusading face of the American state
and the the domestic even where security
considerations might come into play
Thanks lovely to see you here
the
well the two questions are not
disconnected the first thing I would say
it's just a slight amendment to your
representation of the first I don't
think we could think of atomic weapons
for example as simply an external threat
I hid under my desk in school we were
given taught that this was some way we
might survive a Russian attack an atomic
attack on New York is unlikely as an
empirical matter that my wooden desk
would have protected me but the the
hardest puzzle or think about 9/11 so
it's not just an external I think that
what's so striking about these matters
was that the the boundary of internal
and external was not just a hard barrier
that couldn't be crossed but was the
kind of border with a lot of
permeability and so that strikes me as
not unimportant because it leads to a
sense of citizens feeling insecure even
in a war like Vietnam which was very far
away and which most of us certainly had
privileged institutions like mine and
this one didn't have to fight
notwithstanding the it was as much a
battle inside as outside in part for the
reasons of those who were vulnerable to
conscription or potentially vulnerable
but also because of the way in which it
came back directly to haunt American
society and became constitutive of many
other struggles going on at the time so
first point which you may or may not
agree with is that I don't fully accept
the distinction between the inside and
outside and I'm struck again if we just
stick for a moment to the period with
which I was primarily dealing early in
the talk
you know it's an Internal Security Act
as well as rules about the draft for
people to go outside in the military and
this this back and forth strikes me as
what is particularly striking about this
this period of post war and to the
present in terms of what I'm calling
enduring exceptions because they they
transcend now there are other emergent
there have been I reread this morning
since the passage in 1976 of the
Emergencies Act have been 59
declarations of emergency by presidents
most are about things like the hurricane
or or occasionally a trade dispute
natural often natural disasters but
these tend to come under the heading of
what I call it impermanent emergencies
you have a declaration about a terrible
hurricane it's about that event whereas
when we have this border crossing of
internal and external threat where we've
gotten zones of exceptions either by
presidential declaration or by a kind of
congressional delegation that that Ian
was underscoring that tends to stick and
cumulate even there are push backs but
then they the rigidity of it seems if
not quite holy and movable
exceptionally difficult to move so I
would distinguish and for that reason I
think it's reasonable not unreasonable I
want to think more about your question
but it's not unreasonable to distinguish
between different kinds of situation and
different kinds of reaction and the very
last thing I'll say will sound abstract
but
both abstracting and creat this is comes
out of a different literature altogether
many years ago in in an internal debate
within Western Marxism Perry Anderson
criticized EP Thompson two great figures
for in his book on the making of the
English working class for using the term
experience as causal in which Thompson
said the experience of the English
working class caused the formation of an
active political working class and
Anderson said no experience it's a it's
a junction term you shouldn't use it
because it means two different things it
means I experienced something
objectively you know someone's suitcase
on the train if it had hit me in the
head today I would have that's an
experience but experience it also means
active learning we gain experience we so
he said it's a messy concept and I
always thought the critique had force
but for but it had precisely the
opposite meaning namely the most
powerful circumstances are junctions
circumstances experience combining the
objective and the subjective situations
that combine the obligation and the
loyalty in this case situations that
combine external exigency and threat
with internal challenges are the ones
that have by far the most power and and
consequence and it's for that reason I
think we should focus hard on them
you'll see that they're a non-trivial
number of figures perhaps even starting
implicitly with Hobbes but certainly
with Carl Schmitt and more recently with
AH Gambon who believed that liberal
democracies simply can't a not only
can't solve this problem they can't
begin to address it meaningfully and
it's that challenge that I'll take up
the next two times
[Music]